paar gemeinden dafür und dann in büros
lesen sollen wir noch warten oder können
wir anfangen ich bräuchte ein signal aus
und wir bräuchten noch ein ohr für den
minister
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir haben soeben einen intensiven und
sehr ernsthaften austausch geführt mit
den vertretern aller großen
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute mit den
sachverständigenrat mit hervorragenden
volkswirten aus ganz deutschland war mir
wichtig diesen dialog zu beginnen weil
wir uns in einer sehr schwierigen
wirtschaftlichen situation befinden und
ich bin sehr dankbar dass der neue
vorsitzende des sachverständigenrates
zur begutachtung der
gesamtwirtschaftlichen lage herr
professor lars feld und bei diesem
kurzen resümee unterstützen wird ich
habe aus diesem austausch eine große
ermutigung mitgenommen weil das
maßnahmenpaket der bundesregierung dass
wir gestern im bundeskabinett
beschlossen haben von allen die sich
geäußert haben begrüßt worden ist also
ein schritt in die richtige richtung als
notwendig und als im prinzip angemessen
und gut
es gibt darüber hinaus eine reihe von
weiterführenden vorschlägen damit
verhindert wird dass aus der pandemie
eine infektion und eine dauerhafte krise
der volkswirtschaft wird wir haben uns
ausgetauscht über wachstumserwartungen
die natürlich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht auf punkt und komma berechnet
werden können aber dass wir
schwerwiegende wirtschaftliche
auswirkungen jetzt schon spüren
durch eine große zunahme von kurzarbeit
das ist von niemandem bestritten
und das eben die häufung von effekten
die durch mangelnde nachfrage aber auch
durch mangelnde angebote weil es an
vorprodukten fehlt weil es krankenstände
gibt sich kumuliert
das alles wird dazu führen dass die
wirtschaftlichen einbußen wahrscheinlich
höher sein werden als in der letzten
wirtschaftskrise in der banken- und
börsenkrise ich sage wahrscheinlich weil
es niemand so genau wissen kann
deshalb sind wir dem sachverständigenrat
auch sehr dankbar dass er uns die
unterschiedlichen szenarien noch einmal
in einem gutachten dargelegt hat wir
haben für die bundesregierung
klargemacht dass wir unser
maßnahmenpaket als den ersten schritt an
sehen dass wir wissen dass die zeitliche
umsetzung kritisch ist das heißt wir
wollen erreichen dass die hilfen
möglichst schnell zur verfügung stehen
um das wegbrechen von strukturen das
wegbrechen von arbeitsplätzen zu
verhindern
wir wissen aber auch dass wir damit nur
den ersten schritt getan haben und dass
wir in enger abstimmung mit den
sozialpartnern mit dem
volkswirtschaftlichen sachverstand den
wir gott sei dank in deutschland in
beeindruckender in beeindruckendem
umfang haben an den universitäten an den
forschungsinstituten gemeinsam schritt
für schritt die maßnahmen ergreifen
müssen die uns aus der krise führen
deshalb war es auch wichtig für uns dass
professor feld in dem gutachten seines
rates noch einmal auch das ja 20 21 in
den blick genommen hat weil wir eben die
perspektiven eines neuen aufschwungs
nach der überwindung der krise nicht aus
den augen verlieren dürfen
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass die
wachstumskräfte dann wenn die zahl der
infektionen zurückgeht dann wenn der das
öffentliche leben wieder hochgefahren
werden kann dann wenn die unternehmen
wieder normal produzieren können dass
dann die auftriebskräfte die oberhand
bekommen das investiert werden kann
das produziert werden kann wir sind
entschlossen und diese aufgabe gemeinsam
zu stellen und deshalb möchte ich jetzt
gerne das wort weiterreichen an herrn
professor feld verbunden mit dem dank an
alle ökonomen die an dieser
telefonschalte videos
teilgenommen haben herr professor fällt
vielen dank daher genauso mit einer
ganzen reihe von ökonomen mit einer ganz
tiefen volkswirten die maßnahmen der
bundesregierung auch die gewählten
instrumente begrüßt haben
sie haben es erwähnt wir haben von
seiten des sachverständigenrates der
bundesregierung ein sondergutachten
vorgelegt man kann ja was die
auswirkungen anbetrifft nur in szenarien
denken sich überlegen wie lange dauert
denn der shutter und den wir gegenwärtig
beobachten wie lange dauern
erholungsphasen hieß es in bestimmte
branchen von dem gegenwärtigen starter
und betroffen ist in vollzeit des
sachverständigenrats optimistischer das
ist ein wachstumseinbruch aufs ganze
jahr hochgerechnet
wenn wir ein haus szenario realisieren
können vielleicht nicht ganz so schlimm
kommt wie wir das jüngst von anderen
forschungsinstituten erhört haben
ohne die jetzt zahlen zu nennen ist
völlig klar dass es davon abhängt wie
sehr und wie stark wir diesen staat dann
beibehalten müssen und wir haben das
gutachten zugeschrieben aber auch wenn
der vorherige diskussion ja miteinander
besprochen dass man auch die zeit die
wir jetzt in der kontaktsperre haben
auch nutzen muss um gegebenenfalls
andere gesundheitspolitische strategien
zu ermöglichen also beispielsweise dass
wir flächen texte testverfahren
einsetzen können und ähnliches denn
davon hängt es am ende ab wie stark die
wirtschaftlichen einbrecher sein werden
zum zweiten die maßnahmen die die
bundesregierung hat
sind sehr begrüßenswert ich sind sehr
schnell getroffen worden
das ist das instrumentarium das jetzt
auch hilft in der kurzen frist hilft die
liquiditätsprobleme dies in der
wirtschaft gibt zu überwinden und auch
dafür zu sorgen dass die
arbeitslosigkeit nicht so schnell nach
oben geht oder gegebenenfalls sogar
insgesamt niedrig bleiben kann was man
hinsichtlich der liquidität hilfe das
ist ja noch mal hinzufügen muss die
unternehmen die jetzt besonders stark
betroffen sind sind ja unternehmen die
eher klein sind kleinunternehmen
kleinstunternehmen die wir dann ich
haben müssen die sicher auch ein problem
haben mit weiteren krediten
zurechtzukommen einen schulden überhang
bei kleinen unternehmen bedeutet ja am
ende dass sie schwierigkeiten haben
kredite nicht mehr zurückzahlen zu
können
und von daher sind die zuschüsse die es
in diesem programm der bundesregierung
gibt sehr begrüßenswert wir hoffen dass
die schnell an die unternehmen
ausgezahlt werden können
und vielleicht können wir an manchen
stellen darüber hinaus noch einmal über
mögliche liquiditätshilfen in der ein
oder anderen form nachdenken die
bundesregierung findet möglichkeiten
hier dein gehen nochmal voranzugehen
wir werden für die phase nach abklingen
der gesundheitspolitischen maßnahmen
auch überlegen müssen welche
initialzündungen von seiten des staates
in form von expansiven fiskal
politischen massnahmen angezeigt sind ob
die er auf der steuerlichen seite
anzusiedeln werden oder er auf der
ausgabenseite
das wird dann noch zu diskutieren sein
ende viel hängt am ende auch davon ab
dass wir schnell wieder aus der krise
herauskommen und dass wir im schritt
danach für das jahr 20 21 einen ähnlich
starken und schnellen aufschwung anlegen
wie wir in der finanzkrise in den
folgejahren dann erlebt haben um wieder
auf den alten wachstumspfad
zurückzufinden
das wahrscheinlichste szenario aus sicht
des sachverständigen als ist im moment
ein haus szenario als risiko
alternativen sind
was frau oder eine entwicklung also
längere zeit dies dann dauert bis die
wirtschaft wieder anzieht
wir gehen nicht davon aus gegenwärtig
dass er in ein held kommen also dann
dauerhaft auch eine längere fahrt
längerer zeit auf einen widriger
wachstumspfad werden sondern wir gehen
eigentlich davon aus dass die erholung
wieder gut möglich ist vielen dank
vielen dank bewertung sind uns in der
tat einig geworden dass die auswirkungen
auf die konjunktur beträchtlich sein
werden aber auch dass es sehr stark
davon abhängig sein wird welche
maßnahmen wir kurzfristig ergreifen dort
sind wir auf einem guten weg und was wir
dann tun um mittel- und langfristig die
wachstumskräfte zu stärken dazu sind wir
entschlossen wir haben jetzt noch zeit
für einige wenige nachfragen vonseiten
der journalisten
die erste hat er drauf hätte vom spiegel
bitte sagen sie an wen sich die frage
gerichtet und dann nehmen wir hier aus
dem raum noch herrn könig und
herrencreme mit die eine frage ja halt
mal fällt können sie nochmal ein
bisschen präzisieren welche
konjunkturdelle sie erwarten das ifo
institut sprach von mindestens 5 wo
liegen sie ist das zu pessimistisch zu
optimistisch und auch herr altmann ja
noch mal ganz konkret es gibt
offensichtlich eine lücke großen
unternehmen wird geholfen
kleinunternehmen oder kleinstunternehmen
dazwischen die mittelständischen
schlagen alarm vielleicht können sie
dann noch mal was zu sagen wie ihnen
geholfen werden soll
der professor wenn ich das wenn sie
möchten
ich bin jetzt an dieser stelle bisschen
zurückhaltend zahlen zu nennen denn wir
sind ja was die veröffentlichung des
sondergutachtens angebracht auch mit der
bundesregierung noch im gespräch aber
kann sagen dass die bandbreite des tuspo
instituten seien szenarien an gibt es
sind alles eine 18 szenario wie das
umgerechnet von 5% bis 20% gehen
wir sind im sachverständigenrat bei
wenigen aus unserer sicht dann ja in der
bandbreite wahrscheinlichere
möglichkeiten bei niedrigeren einbrüchen
angekommen also wenn es ein v ist bei
denen wir fünf wochen schatz dauern und
drei wochen erholung haben dann liegen
wir auch unter den fünf prozent die das
ifo-institut angibt wenn es länger
dauert also der shutter und sieben
wochen andauert und die erholung fünf
wochen dann landen wir etwa in der
größenordnung des einbruchs den wir
während der finanzkrise hatten bei einem
u wenn er ähnliche art und weise wobei
die erholung dann länger dauert vor
allen dingen 20 21 das wachstum auch
noch schwächer bleiben würde wenn man
also eine längere phase hat die beim tal
der wirtschaftlichen entwicklung
verbringen die ganz pessimistischen
szenarien die im zweistelligen bereich
gehen die schließen der gegenwärtigen
sachverständige aus wir gehen nicht
davon aus dass wir eine so schwierige
lage bekommen werden man muss ja bei
allem auch mit bedenken dass das erste
quartal dieses jahres noch sehr sehr gut
gelaufen ist also wenn wir die krise
nicht gehabt wenn wir sagen
die abkühlung eure seit dem zweiten
halbjahr 20 18 über das jahr 2019 die
damit verbundenen industrie rezession
die könnten überwunden sein und es gab
viele anzeichen dass immer mal stärker
nach oben gehen das erste quartal wird
sich auch dann entsprechend aus jetzt
kommt corona hinzu und wenn es uns
gelingt ab dem
dritten quartal habe der hälfte des
dritten quartals wieder kräftige
erholung voran zu gehen dann sind wir
eben bei weitem nicht so pessimistisch
das institut ist in einem extremszenario
ja das ist und es liegt noch ein
bisschen an uns welches von diesen
szenarien eintritt und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir weiterhin im gespräch
bleiben und unsere mal so mal so
sollte sich herausstellen dass es lücken
gibt dass es bereiche gibt übersehen
wurden wird die bundesregierung
selbstverständlich handeln
aber ich möchte darauf hätte auf ihre
frage sagen dass ich zum
augenblicklichen zeitpunkt diese lücke
nicht sehe denn das was wir zur
kurzarbeit beschlossen haben
das ist die großzügigste regelung die es
jemals zur kurzarbeit in deutschland
gegeben hat und die gilt eben für die
ganz kleinen unternehmen wie auch für
den mittelstand die mittelgroßen und den
größeren mittelstand wie auch für die
ganz großen unternehmen die gilt für
alle 45 millionen
beschäftigungsverhältnisse soweit die
sozialversicherungspflichtig sind in
deutschland es ist durchgängig das
zweite das was wir bereits vor zehn
tagen angekündigt haben eine umfassende
steuerstundung und vollstreckung schutz
bis ende des jahres im hinblick auf
auswirkungen der korona pandemie auch
das gilt für alle
vom kleinen solo selbstständigen bis zum
großen unternehmen mit zehntausenden von
beschäftigten einschließlich des
mittelstandes der mehr als minister
besonders wichtig ist und wir haben dann
maßgeschneiderte angebote nämlich für
den breiten mittelstand ein umfassendes
bürgschafts garantie und kreditprogramm
in unbegrenzter höhe zu sehr
vorteilhaften konditionen aber davon
ausgehen dass nach dem überwinden der
talsohle von der ja auch professor feld
gesprochen hat wir dann auch wieder sehr
gute wachstumschancen in vielen
bereichen haben und dann ist es auch
vertretbar dass dann diese kredite über
einen längeren zeitraum wieder
zurückgezahlt werden so wie der bund die
schulden
aufnehmen muss ebenfalls wieder
zurückzahlen wird
in dem augenblick in dem die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung besser
verläuft
wir haben dann drittens für unternehmen
die von strategischer bedeutung für
unser land sind das können ganz große
sein es können aber auch mittlere
unternehmen seien die besonders wichtige
technologien vorantreiben
besonders große systemrelevanz haben
haben wir einen stabilisierungsfonds
geschaffen um diese unternehmen vor der
insolvenz und vor übernahmen durch
feindliche übernahmen zu schützen
das ist aber kein rechtsanspruch sondern
das ist sozusagen jeweils eine
entscheidung der bundesregierung in
absprachen rückkopplung mit dem
parlament über einen eigenen ausschuss
den wir dafür einrichten wo es darum
geht die nationalen interessen dieses
landes zu legen und zu realisieren so
dass man also sieht wir haben über die
ganze breite der wirtschaft ein angebot
unterbreitet und jetzt kommt es darauf
an dass dieses angebot auch tatsächlich
in anspruch genommen werden kann
dort arbeiten wir fieberhaft an den
voraussetzungen ich habe die hoffnung
dass die ersten beihilfen die zuschüsse
für die ganz kleinen unternehmen noch in
dieser woche ausgezahlt werden können
zumindest in einigen bundesländern
da wird zum schluss kulissen bitte nur
noch eine letzte frage herr cremer von
heute
ich hätte eine frage zur europäischen
dimension von den ökonomen kommt der
vorschlag den europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus den esm
anzuzapfen und zwar über kreditlinien
also wir reden nicht über coco bonds
oder eurobonds weil das lange dauern
würde sondern halt schnell an das
bestehende geld des esm ranzukommen
wie ist ihre position dazu ja ich kann
uns ich kann uns nur empfehlen dass wir
tatsächlich keine geister und gespenster
debatten führen
aus ideologischen gründen in dem jeder
wieder seine lieblings lösung von vor
fünf oder zehn jahren hervor holt
deshalb bin ich froh dass diese debatte
über eurobonds und ähnliches keine große
reiten wirkung gefunden hat zweitens ist
uns natürlich wichtig dass wir
europäische solidarität nicht nur
beweisen sondern auch implementieren
das hat auch etwas damit zu tun dass die
europäischen volkswirtschaften auf das
engste verflochten sind und dass auch
eine nachhaltige erholung unserer
deutschen volkswirtschaft nur denkbar
ist wenn sich die wirtschaft im euroraum
insgesamt berappelt und auf die beine
kommt es findet heute zu dieser stunde
eine sitzung der euro-gruppe in brüssel
stand der der bundesfinanzminister
teilnimmt also die findet nicht in
brüssel stattfindet wird von brüssel aus
koordiniert und findet per video schalte
in die nationalen hauptstädte statt
dort wird über pragmatische und flexible
lösungen gesprochen ein wichtiges
element ist er der große schutzschirm
denen die ezb die europäische
zentralbank noch einmal ausgebreitet hat
die anderen fragen müssen diskutiert und
entschieden werden aber noch einmal es
geht nicht um einen grundsätzlichen
strategiewechsels und aus ideologischen
gründen das wäre zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
falsch und deshalb werden wir das noch
nicht mitmachen dann herzlichen dank an
alle beteiligt wir müssen leider zum
schluss kommen und an
[Musik]